reunidos por fin el jamón ya no va de 86
años es recibida por sus dos hijos a su
llegada a kiev
rezo cada día por los soldados que nos
defienden que tengan valor dios que
tengan fuerza
mucha nova fue una de las últimas
residentes en ser evacuadas de irving su
marido decidió quedarse su hijo román
que pudo escapar antes cuenta los
horrores que presenció
vimos como los coches que intentaban
salir de la ciudad eran aplastados por
los tanques coches con gente adentro
la estratégica ciudad situada al oeste
de la capital se convirtió en el emblema
de la devastación y de la resistencia de
ucrania en los primeros días de la
invasión se vio a decenas de miles de
personas cruzando un río helado por
debajo del puente principal de irp in
destruido por las fuerzas ucranianas en
un intento de frenar el avance de rusa a
pesar de los bombardeos la gente ha
seguido saliendo el presidente volodymyr
selenski que calificó de buena noticia
la reconquista de irving advirtió que la
zona sigue bajo fuego hemos liberado el
pin buen trabajo los ocupantes están
siendo empujados lejos de irving
empujados lejos de kiev pero aún es
demasiado pronto para hablar de una
situación segura en esta parte de
nuestra región los combates continúan
selenski dijo que las zonas al norte de
kiev siguen controladas por las tropas
rusas y que la situación sigue siendo
difícil en regiones de todo el país como
xoom y jarkiv bombas y el sur